TAKE THE KILL SHOT ON FLYNN, A
CLAIM THAT CLAPPER DENIES.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION TO
THESE BIG DEVELOPMENTS IS THE
ATTORNEY FOR MICHAEL FLYNN,
SIDNEY POWELL.
SIDNEY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THAT POINT
WHICH IS MADE HERE.
IN YOUR FILING, TO SAY THAT
SOMEBODY IS TAKING A "KILL SHOT"
IS DRAMATIC.
IN THE FILING IT SAYS THE
DEFENSE HAS REQUESTED THE PHONE
RECORDS OF JAMES CLAPPER TO
CONFIRM HIS CONTACT WITH
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTER
IGNATIUS, ESPECIALLY ON
JANUARY 10TH 2017 WHEN CLAPPER
TOLD IGNATIUS, INWARDS TO THE
EFFECT OF "TAKE THE KILL SHOT ON
FLYNN."
DID HE ACTUALLY SAY TAKE THE
KILL SHOT ON FLYNN?
WHAT DO YOU SAY "WORDS TO THE
EFFECT OF?"
>> OBVIOUSLY I WASN'T A PARTY TO
THE CONVERSATION, SO I AM TRYING
TO GIVE HIM THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT THERE.
BUT YES, WE REQUESTED HIS PHONE
RECORDS TO COOPERATE THE TIMING
AND EVERYTHING ABOUT THAT CALL
THAT WE CAN POSSIBLY COOPERATE.
IT'S VERY CONCERNING, OF COURSE
THERE WAS A LEAK OF THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL WITH
KISLYAK THE SAME TIME.
AND TWO DAYS AFTER THAT, THE
IGNACIO STORY BREAKS LESS THAN
TWO DAYS ACTUALLY.
>> Jason: WHERE'S THE EVIDENCE
THAT CONVERSATION AND THOSE
WORDS ARE THE EFFECT OF THOSE
WORDS ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE?
>> I CANNOT REVEAL THE SOURCE
RIGHT NOW BUT I DO HAVE A VERY
GOOD SOURCE FOR THAT INFORMATIO
INFORMATION.
>> Jason: YOU'D BELIEVE THE
DEFERMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WITHHOLDING THAT INFORMATION
FROM YOU?
>> I BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS WITHHOLDING A LOT OF
INFORMATION AS IT IS WITH
MR. CLAPPER, MR. BRENNAN AND ON
THE PEOPLE WHO PURCHASE PAID IN
THE COMPLETE SET UP OF
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN.
WE HAVE FOUND ADDITIONAL TEXT
MESSAGES THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SUPPRESSED INCLUDING WHERE AGENT
STROZK, THE PRECASE FOR
GENERAL FLYNN, THEY KNEW THERE
WAS NO LOGAN ACT VIOLATION.
THEY EXONERATED HIM COMPLETELY
OF BEING AN AGENT OF RUSSIA BY
THE END OF JANUARY AND YET
MR. COMEY STILL RUNS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE ON FEBRUARY 14TH AND
CONJURES UP THE ENTIRE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE NARRATIVE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT WHEN FLYNN
HAS BEEN CLEARED LONG BEFORE
THAT.
ALSO INFORMATION THAT THESE
AGENTS DID MANIPULATE THE 302.
IT WAS LONG AND OVER WITH THE
LIBERTY OF" DATE WHICH IS HIGHLY
UNUSUAL IN AND OF ITSELF.
A COMPARISON OF THE
FEBRUARY 10TH AND FEBRUARY 11TH
302 PLURALIST WHICH SHOWS THE
ADDITION OF SUBSTANTIAL CLAIMS
THAT WERE NOT IN THERE BEFORE
AND NOT SUPPORTED BY THE NOTES
WHICH WE ALSO ATTACHED.
SO PEOPLE CAN GO TO THE ACTUAL
DOCUMENT AND READ IT AND SEE IT
FOR THEMSELVES.
IT'S EXTREMELY CONCERNING.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS GOVERNMENT
MISCONDUCT.
THE AGENTS DELIBERATELY
CALCULATED AND MET TO PLAN AND
STRATEGIZE HOW TO AMBUSH AND
REBUKE GENERAL FLYNN WITHOUT
LETTING HIM KNOW HE WAS
OFFICIALLY UNDER ANY KIND OF
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, TO KEEP
THEM RELAXED, AND THEY WANTED TO
BE SEEN AS ALLIES WHEN IN FACT
THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE HAD
SAID IN THE CONVERSATIONS AND
THE INTENDED TO CREATE A
SITUATION IN WHICH ANYTHING HE
SAID COULD BE USED AGAINST HIM
LATER AS A FALSE STATEMENT
WITHOUT ANY WARNINGS TO THAT
EFFECT WHATSOEVER.
>> Jason: REALLY QUICKLY, I'VE
GOT TO GO HERE.
YOU BELIEVE LISA PAGE IS THE ONE
WHO EDITED THE SO-CALLED 302
WHICH IS THE SUMMARY OF THE
INTERVIEW WITH GENERAL FLYNN,
CORRECT?
>> SHE ADMITTED MAKING SOME
EDITS OF IT.
I DO NOT KNOW AND WE DO NOT KNOW
YET UNTIL WE GET THE MATED DATA
FROM THE FBI WHO MADE THE MAJOR
EDITS TO IT.